I've definitely developed a nasty case
of hypno phobia and generally suffer
from anxiety surrounding sleep it's
become a significant negative force in
my life cause unknown I'm rather well
put together and successful across many
domains any advice yes go to bed later
so one of the things that happens to
people when they're having a hard time
going to sleep and their sleep is
disrupted is that they tend to go to bed
earlier to catch up on their sleep and
that actually has a counter that's cut
that works at counter purpose as to what
they're trying to attempt what you want
to do is delay your sleep until you're
really quite tired so stay up much later
get up at the same time in the morning
game but move your sleep time later
maybe half an hour night till you
actually do fall asleep the other thing
that you could look into is that there
are relaxation exercises behavior
therapists offered those but I'm sure
you could find one online at breathing
exercises and so often what you do is
imagine you're laying in your bed and
you're nervous and so what you do is you
concentrate on your feet and you flex
your toes and then breathe in and out
and relax them and then you flex your
ankles or the soles of your feet and
breathe in and out and relax and do that
with every muscle group all the way up
your body and remember to breathe deeply
and regularly and that can help regulate
your anxiety so I would say stay up
later till you're clearly tired the
other thing you might try is sleeping in
a different room and then the the final
thing is there are pretty effective
sleep medications like zap Leblon for
example which is seems to be pretty
effective and if you're really having a
hard time sleeping maybe you could try
something like that and see if it and
see if it helps you don't have to try it
forever but so the simplest thing to do
though is to go to bed later and because
you'll be more tired and more likely to
fall asleep then and
it's really not gonna cause you any
trouble so that's what I recommend